naja was geht hier zur max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video ich habe
in letzter zeit festgestellt dass mir
relativ schwer fällt alleine videos zu
machen die ich cool finden und deshalb
habe ich heute obwohl ich alleine bin
mein bruder escape bei was willst du
gerade ein nasenloch alter geht es ja
auch der hat auch seine kamera
aufgenommen wir machen heute zusammen
eine kleine challenge beziehungsweise
viele ganz kleinen challenges um genau
zu sein wir machen nämlich die sieben
sekunden challenge das funktioniert
folgendermaßen wir haben gegenseitig
fünf aufgaben füreinander vorbereitet
wie wir in fünf minuten bewältigen
müssen sozusagen und ich würde sagen
nein lieber sk ich geb dir die
allererste sieben sekunden challenge
okay ja ich gucke auf und zwar hast du
sieben sekunden zeit um drei youtuber zu
imitieren
es gibt nur ein youtube bild mein lisa
der jungen liebe nudeln ok ersten
youtube erhält schwierig so leute ihr
versteht wahrscheinlich jetzt schon zu
den reiz von der change es ist manchmal
schwierig innerhalb von sieben sekunden
an so viele sachen zu denken und das
macht den reiz aus ok fluges dran
ok durchs leben der kunden für drei hits
von moneyball steige aus dem petrisberg
auf ich sage und prompt gelang es war
daher besonders dass erstmalig die namen
gesagt liga hält das land auch das waren
die titel ich habe hier auch gesungen
aber es waren gleichzeitig auch die
titel
so sind mal so sind moneyball songs da
sind die namen die titel ihr könnt auch
gerne in die kommentare schreiben wir
dieses setup findet also dass wir das
zusammen machen obwohl wir an
unterschiedlichen orten sind das könnte
ja auch mit unterschiedlichsten youtuber
einmal machen wie findet ihr schreibt in
die kommentare
ich muss sagen nicht wunder leute wenn
ich immer bis nach unten schauen weil
ich hier unten so da bücher aufgebaut um
ein handy dagegen gewehrt habe pauli
noch fest an die praxis reaktion sehen
kann und deswegen schon einmal runter
und hören können
du hast jetzt mein lieber eskimo bei 7
sekunden zeit um eine line gegen miguel
pablo zu bitten mir hallo du bist dumm
ich kann mich nicht mal darum und du
hast das innerhalb von sieben sekunden
geschafft okay so leute damit haben wir
schon mal
der mensch hat einen gefallen getan und
nächste aufgabe du hast sieben sekunden
zeit für drei bundesstaaten der usa
colorado north carolina south carolina
new york massachusetts tennessee die
nächste zu hast mein lieber freund
sieben sekunden zeit um die reine hose
auf den kopf zu ziehen
es war auf jeden fall rechtlich okay so
aufbereiten dass die hose tiefer morgen
trainiert habe ich euch jetzt hinterher
oft geschrieben ich mach ich mir jetzt
bist du bist du noch mit der nächsten
sieben sekunden challenge du hast sieben
sekunden zeit mehr
drei sorten wie zu nennen california
kurs perthel heyland lemonade warum hast
du das getan
ich hab's gemacht ich find's kontext
geben weil ich immer irgendwie scheiße
über über riga ich bin und ich benutzt
das wort einfach gerne und du hast jetzt
sieben sekunden zeit um bis 30 zu zählen
107 19 23 25 13 25 20 an franz rolf ok
das waren 6 und wir könnten oder so ein
nicht schlecht nicht weglassen sich am
ärgert mich selbst mal vor gezählt und
beschallte kitty wie lange dauert der
bundeswehr ist bislang bis 30 c sehr gut
geschafft
ich habe mich wirklich gezählt ich habe
einfach so angefangen 25 68 19
dann habe ich einfach irgendwas spielen
sprach irgendwelche laute gemacht du
hast du hast geglaubt dass ich manchmal
ein bisschen dumm sagte mir in sieben
sekunden fünf spieler der deutschen
nationalmannschaft
ok hummels
boateng müller schürrle royce wassers
genommen hat nicht ganz gereicht aber
ich war auch eine vier mal hat sich
bereit ich weil ich das schon vier oder
von 4
ich fühle mich sicher ich werde im
schnitt gesehen leute und depression
einfach einen fehler
ja du hast jetzt sieben sekunden zeit um
in vier sprachen hallo zu sagen hallo
hallo wenn die halo wird heute dann was
ich weiß dann wieder war es ziemlich
schnell ansonsten was es nicht geschafft
natürlich halo 1 1 7 sekunden change hat
mein bruder für mich dann war's das auch
schon berlin wunderschön video heraus
nicht so wärmt man sich auch leute von
773 amerikanische minecraft youtuber
captains parkes minecraft okay aus
mexiko deswegen sei es okay ich glaube
ich habe nichts verkackt außer diese
nationalmannschafts geschickt hast du
etwas verkackt die erste direkt
es war es aber vom heutigen video ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen ich bin euer
junger max und bis zum nächsten mal
sebastian